yo John Luke John Luke hey yeah check
this out no for real check this out I've
got I've got the collector edition a
monster hunter right here
oh do bring that over heck yeah it's
doing unboxing let's do this let's check
out one get get there we go out here
sunroof not again not like last time
please alright thank you thank you
alright so let's let's dig into this
it's got some real real resilient
plastic you look here I think I think
I've gotten
so help what's your in this thing what's
in this thing I believe there's a red
statue of the flagship monster the naree
gan say oh I'm gonna pull this out of
here throw it throw it away okay we
don't need this all I get a scholar goal
of sleeve I'm kind of a nice nice
exclusive content also it's got
everything all along there yeah here see
what suit looking we can find out what's
I think I got the front or the back of
this whoa
nailed it all right so first things
first we've got the game game Oh like
the box it's a very nice box a cool
little rat loose on the front we've got
the code here for the deluxe kit which I
believe includes a couple of transmog
armors okay it's like a samurai 1s
totally cool stuff so we're not gonna
show you the code for that
and a special soundtrack download thing
Wilson I show the code for that this is
like the full soundtrack that's cool
yeah which is a fantastic soundtrack
nothing extra in the box I'm sure you
know just a normal box ooh now we're
getting into the good stuff the monster
designs art book oh this would actually
be pretty rad because I mean that's like
the whole thing of the game right yeah
so it's it's kind of got like this nice
little little bumpy you can kind of feel
it all out give it a good feel it's like
you're actually petting the narragansett
which will actually be able to do here
in a second with properly right so we've
got cool drawings of Oliver or favorite
monster boys who have been doing us a
good murder like every monster it's it's
not too thick but it's pretty thick
no seems like they're saving it they
don't show everything they said they
don't feel at all good but they're the
really cool they've got references for
the armor that they give the weapons
they give and the actual monsters
themselves oh that's right
I like that that's really cool and the
the big thing we've got right here if I
can pull this out I appreciate your help
with this situation okay here we go I
hear that so move this off to the side
too and in here we have oh we go again
that one came out a lot easier though
and just kind of pop this out oh it's
tapes
[Music]
okay that's actually pretty small so
inside of this box we've got this oh but
it's really detailed very detailed that
pointy detailed statue of an heir he
gone - he's uh didn't end up beating him
in the beta he's a very frightening
frightening monster
that's real yeah that's cool this got
him in his natural habitat spiky things
live in other spiky things of course
okay so yeah that's everything in this
and do you know much it costs
yeah I believe it's one hundred and
fifty dollars okay USD but you get some
really cool armor effects to kind of put
yourself in a place where you you look
cooler than other people
this really cool statue that art book is
it's really really rad and a digital
download code for the soundtrack I'm
gonna take that soundtrack code that
game is I'll give you know we can see
some we can do some listening party type
yeah exactly
we'll turn up to some monster on her
jams yeah I like it yeah alright cool
move it this other way I gotta eat my
burrito Oh what I mean I guess it is
you're not next to us please my walk
right think of think of the think of the
collectors a [ __ ] I'm we're I gonna move
it trouble please